we got a former Anheuser-Busch executive
slamming inauthentic Bud Light for
having lost track of the consumer
there's a bunch of developments for one
their restaurant volume is decline has
has dropped 34.7 percent
we're hearing that various different
sales metrics show a drop of like 17 in
general sales volume is decreased in
double digits and uh here's my favorite
latest development on the Bud Light
boycott story it is first I'd like to
bring you all back in time to April 13th
for this CNN article Bud light's
inclusive ad campaigns are good for
business
and then we get this masterpiece
Bud Light sales are falling but
Distributors say they're sticking by the
brand uh shots
oh you'll love to see it I love this
guys screenshot those two uh I should I
should actually just do this right now
I'm the first one of Jim Cramer byline
yeah right Jim Kramer bye Bud Light
so they'll make statements like this
inclusive ad campaigns are good for
consumers okay this is circular yes if
an ad campaign is truly inclusive as in
it is maximally appealing to the largest
base possible then yes it's going to be
an effective ad campaign clearly okay
clearly Bud Lights ad campaign was not
inclusive right it was not inclusive
because they alienated their own viewers
so let me give an example name an
incredibly controversial group of people
I don't want to be like lazy and say the
Irish the the Irish No Name a group
people generally let's say um antifa
antifa okay
so if a marketing but part of why this
might break down is because you could
almost actually see this happening
The Firm said you know what we're going
to be really inclusive we're going to
include antifa and our next
advertisement you go we'll hold on a
second okay by including them you're
excluding everyone who takes issue with
them so inclusive does it mean welcoming
a new group right it means how are we
going to get the most possible people
right to be loyal to our brand and
here's and here's here's an important
distinction as it pertains to say
political ideology
there's a big divide in this country and
it's roughly down the middle in terms of
politics so you risk alienating half the
population by choosing say stay away
from it but then you can make the
argument about when it comes to race
well there's Millions hundreds of
millions tens of millions of people of
varying different racial backgrounds and
a tiny bit of racists so you know what
if we want to maximize our total market
share we go for a literal inclusive
strategy which is apolitical and just as
everybody's chill to have our beer
instead they go directly for the most
polarizing and divisive and and like
nails on a chalkboard personality and
then just gut their brand exactly they
didn't make it inclusive they made it as
exclusive as possible exactly let's push
everyone out outside of our small group
of people who feel a need to Virtue
signal to one another that we think this
is a beautiful woman definitely that's
what we're looking here woman and
beautiful so sloppy so I I saw I forgot
who it was because I'd love to give him
credit it was on Twitter someone
basically came up with you want to
appeal to the trans Community okay
here's a here's an idea right okay
you're you're a Bud Light Factory and
you've got a person there they are a
factory worker and they're they're trans
or a little bit scared to come to work
and they get there and they're and their
friends welcome them in okay well there
now you've done an ad that's that's not
alienating it's maybe welcome to it but
they went in the most clunky you know
embarrassing way possible and yet talk
about the language experts say I mean
literally I know I know anytime a
headline has experts say just just
distrust it
experts say is the blue check mark of uh
news articles but I will mention this I
actually think even an advertisement
like that wouldn't work for Bud Light
because the consumers would go this is
obvious virtue signaling they're trying
to be a woke brand and that's not who
Bud Light is generally marketed itself
towards that's not who buys Butler
that's the craziest thing about this
leftist ideology is that they're willing
to earn the entire house exactly just
for the sake of their ideology and
looking like they're doing the right
thing and I don't know that's going off
for their friends that's why I say it's
not really an ideologist it's a cult
it's a chaotic destructive force that
has no end game maybe the end game is
destroying the country maybe they're
being wielded by by evil people to
destroy things but that's all they do
consume and Destroy and and we talk
about a person who bought into the cult
I mean part of the problem with the Bud
Light thing was the also podcast with
the VP of marketing it's explaining why
the brand that she is a part of is bad
essentially that's why it's too fratty
and we have to change it that that's
your problem when you when you pair that
with the Dylan Mulvaney video which was
again I mean who is is buying Bud Light
because of that are Dylan Mulvaney's
fans buying Bud Light because of that I
can't even imagine that anyone thought
this was a good idea oh my gosh and yet
and this is what you get well now that I
think about it Tim cast probably isn't
doing enough to be inclusive and to
reach out to these liberals so we're
going to replace Sheamus with what genk
yuger of The Young Turks you can't
replace me and then your Stock's gonna
go down a billion dollars I'll be like
the Tucker Carlson of Tim cast experts
say it's actually it might be good to
say it'd be a great idea experts say
having to alienate his entire viewer
base yeah right telling your customers
telling your audience telling your fans
that uh they're bad people tends not to
work out for you yeah shockingly enough
shockingly enough uh it's so bizarre but
this is just what happens right people
don't understand the brands that they're
trying to create advertisements for and
sometimes they can get away with it I
remember last year we had Libby Emmons
here and we were maybe this is a year
and a half ago now but we were watching
these different woke advertisements that
candy companies were doing it was a
bunch of different brands oh the M M's
thing from Tucker Carlson is that you're
talking about oh no no no I'm talking
about the one where the witch comes in
and basically kills the kid with magic
but that's not exactly that happens yes
don't you remember we were watching the
commercial and reviewing it this kid has
like a witch babysitter and she comes in
and she like the kid does something
gender non-conforming and so it was
supposed to be a woke commercial you
remember this well we reviewed it on air
and made fun of it and we were looking
at a couple bow commercials but you know
sometimes Brands can sort of get away
with it because even though their their
product is a political the consumers
aren't going to Care all that much but
with Bud Light I mean you're really
talking about something that is marketed
generally again towards Friday dudes and
also Working Class People it is a cheap
beer it your audience is toxic
masculinity right that's that's such a
good point though because like so in
uncovered I write about something like I
call guilt journalism when you there I I
specifically cite there was a magazine
Cosmo that put on the cover this
gigantic obese woman and it just with
the headline this is healthy this is
healthy now are you sure right if you
want to put on the headline you know
want to put this person on the cover
okay but what it what are we seeing here
what are we doing well it's because they
feel this guilt over what they've done
for decades of putting real thin women
on their cover and what that has caused
and so now they feel this guilt it's
like a pre-cancellation we're gonna just
we're gonna just get ahead of this and
and say oh no no no now this is healthy
now we're see we're the good people and
honestly in some ways that feels like
what that Bud Light marketing executive
was saying too it's like we're we're a
bad brand so let's get let's become good
now but we feel guilty about what we've
done exactly well they wanted to court a
higher class of consumers that's a
general idea the white men are bad right
working class men are bad right all the
people who are considered toxically
masculine conservatives the Frat Boys we
we know what their dog whistling when
they talk about this and so what do we
need well we need a trendy younger hip
viewer base you know people who would
have higher Social credit scores so to
speak and that's who we need to try to
Market to so we're going to spit in the
face of our current consumer Base by
marketing to them with something that we
are explicitly saying isn't for them
because what we're trying to say is this
brand is not for you anymore go away
yep and then when they go away
yeah I just want to get back to doing
regular stuff and not getting preached
at do you remember Gillette you guys
remember the Gillette ad I'm sure when
that guy another great example
right yes there's the part where the
dude sees the attractive woman and he
goes like Oh and he tries to walk with
the other guy stops him he's like no
don't don't talk don't talk to women
he's like women are gross bro no
actually Jeremy's raised I think it was
a Dollar Shave Club thing right yeah
I'm sorry sorry cancel their ads yeah
but um that Gillette ad too it was so
ridiculous because
they took so rough and tumble play which
all of the psychological literature
shows is incredibly important and
necessary for the development of young
boys it portrays it as two little boys
just beating the crap out of each other
and the Two Dads at the grill going well
boys will be boys is if that's what real
life is right they took a gender studies
dissertation made it into an
advertisement and insulted their entire
viewer base because guess what like
those razors are for men they're male
razors and I think this isn't a softer
repeat of that I don't even remember why
Jeremy made chocolate bars at this point
I just know that we have 2 000 of them
downstairs they're good they're actually
pretty good man they have four
ingredients it's like chocolate dried
milk powder and like organic sugar or
something nuts and cocoa butter
almonds what was it it was it was the
Hershey's did the candy bar commercial
with the Trans woman yep and then Jeremy
was like don't buy that chocolate by
okay I will and so I bought two thousand
bars you're such a consumer Tim well I
think you know we we should legitimately
be supporting agreed these efforts so
the moment you know
uh Jeremy's light or whatever comes out
right Brew we'll order that too
um but this is this is the point you
should you should be supporting
companies that are clearly in support of
your values we're this this show was
sponsored by Public Square shout to them
because we're huge fans you can go on
the app and you can find businesses and
it's awesome look in your area figure
out which businesses actually care about
your values and don't give your money to
Bud Light
and then we win yeah well for so long
conservatives have been so reluctant to
do that one massive flaw with the right
people view this is a strength it's not
as much of a strength as they think it
is one massive law on the right is this
almost this this odd desire not to
alienate everyone right and so the left
will claim they don't want to alienate
people but then obviously they shun
anyone who steps out of line even
slightly and the right has always said
well we're just a home for everyone who
considers themselves a non-leftist or or
anti-leftist and so because of that I
think conservatives are very much prided
themselves on being able to have
conversations with people they disagree
with and that that's all well and good
right but I think for a while there was
this stigma that if you as a
conservative didn't tolerate everything
the left was doing then you were just as
bad as the left and I'm glad
conservatives are stepping out of that
saying you know what we can and we
should boycott these Brands and there
actually is something we can do about
this it is weird how the what was it I
was what was it uh um stick sex and
Hammer put out he made a meme and it was
so amazing and it said the actual
political party uh let me let me pull
this up shout out to Sticks I got to
pull this up it was too funny uh and
then uh let me I don't want to ruin the
joke so I'm but uh let me let me let me
get it I'm scrolling I'm scrolling I'll
find it it's in here so I retweeted it
because it was hilarious here we go
check this out it says the two party
system summed up Republican paralyzed
goat Democrat diseased rat
instead of the you know the elephant and
the jackass or whatever it's uh the
Republican paralyzed goat I think
perfectly sums up what the Republican
party is they get startled and then just
lock up and then fall over and the
Democrats are a diseased rat there you
go that is and and I mean I'm not the
individuals not the people
I'm not trying to call people that I'm
saying the political parties and what
they represent like the Republican being
a paralyzed goat is just too perfect
yeah like the diseased rat thing is like
I don't know whatever but the
Republicans are paralyzed goat and
you're trending on Twitter
all right there we go Tim you're done I
can't believe you just said that I don't
care I retweeted sticks I will tweet
this out I hereby agree with this it's
the perfect thing yeah yeah the parties
this is what they represent but really
like I said the Democrat disease rat
thing is kind of like hey okay the
Republicans has paralyzed goats hits the
nail on the hammer too perfectly that's
what they are yeah something startling
comes up
and they fall over
paralyzed goat shout out 6X and Hammer
666 that was a really good one
but that but that's why it's it's been
so difficult to win culture War battles
however disaffected liberals have
aligned themselves with the Republican
Party exactly and now there is for
Republicans a fighting chance so I still
look at it like this we were at the
Turning Point USA event
we are the only ones there it's the
except for Steve Bannon who weren't
wearing we weren't wearing suits
everybody's up on stage wearing some
kind of suit yeah and then we show up
and we're just like I don't know wearing
what we wear looking like schlubs yeah
well I was a black tie event yeah sure
so this this is what I think these young
conservative types is you know look man
if you go to a bunch of high school kids
wearing a suit and you're like hello
there fellow kids they're gonna be like
yeah okay what well you got to be a
wreck you got to be like relaxed and
Casual you know there's clearly a
realignment I mean it's happening I I I
how many people that are they're fans of
the show probably you know consider
themselves potentially conservative but
not Republicans I think that there's
there's a lot of people that that are in
the culture today that are seeing that
where the left is going and saying
that's not me you know I don't know
exactly where I am right now but I I
mean I think about it you talk about
like you know the right could be talk to
anyone right I think that's that's a
good philosophy I agree with that I talk
to anyone and the left right now is not
just the right husband ideas they have
dumb ideas you know conservatives are
stupid but these people are dangerous
yeah and I think that's a huge change
that's actually the and it's coming from
the media too I write I describe them as
anti-speech activists these people that
should be about free speech and allowing
a free flow of ideas on social media or
wherever are now saying no no these
people are dangerous and I actually
think that that young people see that
and say I'm not I'm not going to be a
part of that that's not it's who I am
it's the cult versus the not cult I want
to mention something here too because
the media did spend a lot of time
talking about how much it cared about
Free Speech it's really easy to care
about Free Speech when you're the only
voice but as soon as the Advent of the
internet and your average person being
able to voice your own opinions all of a
sudden we got all of these specials and
different news outlets about
disinformation what we need to do to
ensure that hate speech doesn't spread
online the whole utility of television
in the present era where the internet
exists is I get to talk at you and you
don't get to say anything back right
that's what it's for so we shouldn't be
shocked that the vast majority of India
individuals and Legacy Media don't
believe in free speech because their
platform is fundamentally anti-free
speech it's I get to say what I want and
I don't hear anything back from you so
we're working on a bunch of new projects
obviously we're looking for talent and
we've been talking to some individuals
who are like um and I don't want to be
involved in political stuff and I'm like
look the show that we're launching is
not political in any way it's a it's
totally its own Standalone thing and so
we start working on this and I'll keep
the details vague for now but the
individual said that they started
getting threats of violence insults and
attacks and I was like did you get any
of that from anyone associated with the
right or like disaffected liberals or
like no of course not yeah and I was
like and do you agree with all of these
people it's like no of course not and
I'm like isn't it crazy that someone
like Sheamus who is Catholic staunchly
pro-life can sit here and disagree with
me or Ian or whatever and he's like one
he's one of our best friends we laugh
together he's on the show consistently
there's no beef right yeah there's none
but if if it comes to the left you
disagree on one issue you're route
you're far right you're bad you're evil
this is literally Hitler yeah literally
Hitler this is The Joe Rogan thing
that's so fascinating to me I mean Joe
Rogan is a guy who's if he's supporting
any politician it's Bernie Sanders you
know it's this is the as Progressive as
it can get and yet why does the left
hate him and the corporate media hate
him is because he's impeding on their
power and because he's willing to have
conversations I mean I describe him as
an information maximalist and the media
is now full of information minimalists
they want the minimum amount of
information out there for the public to
consume because really they just
fundamentally distrust people they
distrust their own audience and they
just trust the average American and and
the right it is now all of a sudden in
this position of being oh no actually
you know let's let's get ideas out there
now not the right but Bill Maher and Joe
Rogan these are people that just have a
fundamental disagreement with the way
the left has shifted towards this
anti-free speech platform and I think
the other side of that too though is is
also the left has gotten so crazy in a
lot of their core beliefs now don't with
they don't stand up so to intellectual
scrutiny so if they had their ideas
challenged on social media on these news
programs and people are exposed to one
side and the other side and and the
actual facts like men can't be women men
don't have uteruses you know if we truly
have an actual open debate pretty much
ninety percent of everything they
believe is gonna is gonna be obliterated
yup that's why they don't want to come
on the show yep and every every polite
invite gets turned down we will pay for
your travel we will fly you first class
we will get a car waiting for you with a
guy holding up a sign with your name on
it we'll bring you out there will be a
filet mignon medium rare oscar style
right on this table it was great service
and you can say whatever you want and
they're like no wait
while insulting Tim across from it I'm
saying for leftists we gotta we gotta
pull out of the stocks well that's red
carpet come on down and they're like no
and then you get the grifter ones who
are like just willing to lie cheat and
steal for fame and they're like oh come
on it's like not you yeah and we know
what your game is I'm talking about the
actual personalities we're talking about
leftist politics and policies Jimmy door
came on but we're big fans of Jimmy Dore
he was a he was a regular on Tucker too
right this is thing like there are some
people that I think are are willing to
do it themselves and are willing to have
that exchange but they're just so afraid
of the backlash they're so afraid of
what a few people yelling at them on
Twitter will feel like that that they
don't understand that that is such an
unrepresentative situation when it comes
to what your actual fans what people
that actually like you what would they
would get out of that that I I they're
so warped and living in this bubble of
Twitter which is you know as polls have
shown two percent of all Americans
account for 90 of tweets about politics
I mean it is it's it's unrepresentative
and listen I spend way too much time
Twitter myself I love it I hate that I
love it you know I'm not representative
of this but I try to have some
self-awareness that this is not real
life that people who you know love me on
Twitter or hate me on Twitter it's a
very small cross-section but I I I think
it's becoming real life that's the issue
that's starting to feed into it yeah
well that it has been this you know
Twitter isn't real life was prominent
six seven years ago because people were
hyper online but now there's no middle
anymore yeah now it's to the point where
it really does I like the craziest thing
is I I've had people come to me and be
like oh hey your Tim pool I follow you
on Twitter and I'm like oh do you watch
the show and they're like I should
follow you on Twitter man really okay so
it's like Twitter's influence has become
pronounced which is probably why Elon
Musk was like I have to buy this thing
yeah well I mean a lot of what people
end up deciding to talk about or report
about or discuss on their podcast is
based on what they see trending on
Twitter so it's an incredibly powerful
tool now a lot of people don't realize
is that well Twitter in terms of its
user base is not the furthest left
platform it certainly leans to the left
to the point where if it were a state
for example it would be you know pretty
solidly blue and
a lot of Corporations will look to the
kind of reception they are getting on
Twitter from their advertisement
campaigns to determine whether they
should shift course
and they're getting an incredibly biased
sample and many of them haven't realized
that in the past so you'll get a bunch
of people tweeting at you saying well
this campaign was offensive etc etc all
right well you're you're getting a
biased sample there but corporations
will still make changes based on that
very bio sample thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time